I think there would be humiliation  though because when you ask girls about  their body count like you see it on  these panels they get like all like you  know they're embarrassed about it so  there's got to be some segment of the  female population that would just either  stop or they'd be self-conscious and  then I think about it and I'm like okay  well if less women would be behaving  badly because they'd be worried about  that body count going up there'd be less  guys hooking up with those girls maybe  like that whole hookup culture would  kind of just quiet a little bit I'm  hopeful I'm just kind of I'm just a  thriller like I would like ideally yeah  do I think that would actually happen no  because again like the guys are still  marrying the single mothers they're  still they're still dating the girl that  they know damn well has had 20 30 40  like they they might not have a sign but  they may as well like with Instagram you  might as well have a sign